finley cadillac the sponsors of this
next segment is honoring memorial day by
giving back to the rotary club of green
valley here's how you can celebrate our
heroes with them
welcome my name is emmanuel pinum the
general manager at findlay cadillac
being part of the philly automotive we
like to support local and national
charities and what we're going to talk
about today is the rotary club of green
valley and well we like to support them
because of all the things that they do
in the community i love the whole idea
and the whole mission of serving others
and to talk about that today is delinda
crampton with a rotary club of green
valley yes thank you so much it's great
to be here for the rotary club of green
valley's field of honor and a huge thank
you to findlay cadillac for being one of
our major sponsors and i have to tell
you it is such a spectacular sight we
have 1 000 full-size flags flying at
cornerstone park which is on wigwam
parkway in henderson and it's in honor
of all kinds of heroes in our lives you
know whether they be military um you
know veterans or those who have passed
on before
it could be first responders you know
the firefighters the police the
paramedics or just other heroes that we
have in our lives
they're countless people are honoring
family members and whatnot and every
flag has a tag on it and it says who's
being honored and why
and it's just a really emotional thing
to walk through this field of flags and
read about all the loved ones and why
they play such an important part in
their lives we also honor the victims of
october 1 and we actually are going to
be having one of the october one heroes
speaking at one of our programs that
weekend we're gonna have two programs
one is on saturday evening at 6 00 pm
and that will be honoring first
responders we will also have a program
on the morning of memorial day at 9 00
a.m and that will be honoring our
military and our veterans and i have to
tell you we have an incredible program
lined up for both of those and we're
really hoping that everyone will come
out
and show their support and get to enjoy
a great program at the same time so one
of the things that people can do is they
can purchase a flag it is only forty
dollars and the neat thing is it's a
full-size flag and you can keep it after
the event if you want we also have
sponsorship opportunities starting for
as little as a hundred dollars
and goes all the way up to you know
having your information on the shirts
that we'll be wearing at the event and
media marketing and all that i think the
field of honor is especially important
this year because we are coming through
such a difficult time between covid and
just all the divisiveness that we are
experiencing our country and the field
of honor is a great way to come together
there's no left there's no right we're
all just of one mind and one accord in
honoring our heroes and our loved ones
thank you to finley cadillac for
sponsoring this segment join the rotary
club of green valley's field of honor
may 28th through the 31st at cornerstone
park in henderson head to
greenvalleyrotary.org for more
information and remember the event is
free of charge
all right let's